et trois heures plus tard à l'assemblée
nationale c'était les habituelles
questions d'actualité posées par les
députés de droite ou de gauche questions
sur le fonctionnement de la justice
questions sur la démission du ministre
dominique strauss kahn auquel lionel
jospin rendait hommage en expliquant
aussi ses préoccupations des dernières
heures reportage avec les réactions des
parlementaires recueillis par
jean-baptiste près dali carole comme
bernard connor et valérie du cac grâce
au gouvernement il n'y a plus dominique
strauss kahn sa démission a déjà privé
la droite de certains arguments
hippolyte mais reste la sphère de la
mnef ses répercussions très vite
lionel jospin s'explique pouponnière de
votre parti je voudrais vous dire
clairement quel était mon approche
elle reposait sur trois préoccupations
laisser la justice agir librement
inspiré du principe de respect de la
présomption d'innocence ne pas tirer des
conséquences automatique d'une situation
incertaine en fonction d'une pratique
antérieure qui a vu des personnalités
contrainte à démissionner n'être pas
ensuite condamner dominique strauss kahn
a choisi de prendre la décision que vous
connaissez je lui exprime devant vous
ma sympathie et mon amitié fidèle
j'espère qu'il reviendra vite parmi nous
un hommage et une mise au point
lionel jospin n'interviendra plus
elisabeth guigou elle affrontera
l'opposition à plusieurs reprises et
dans lequel tu dis et des assistants
spécialisés
le sujet les mutations récentes de
magistrats chargés d'affaires
financières dans les couloirs envahis
par les caméras on guette bien sûr les
réactions à droite
elles sont dosés entre la demande
d'explication sur le dos nf et la
modération
encourager la croissance crée la
confiance et l'opposition ne fera pas
comme les socialistes font
de l'acharnement nous sommes dits nous
voulons que la justice passe
elle aurait dû passer depuis longtemps
l'important c'est de savoir quel a été
le rôle du groupe politique qui a
soutenu monsieur jospin et qui est
aujourd'hui un piquet dans l' affaire de
la mnef ça dépasse largement le problème
de
dominique strauss kahn la gauche se fait
plutôt discrète ceux qui veulent
s'exprimer souligne d'abord la
présomption d'innocence qui s'applique à
dominique strauss kahn
il est mis en cause il a le droit à la
présomption d'innocence il va se
défendre mais il est là maintenant pris
dans une sorte de contre 1 qui broie et
qui profondément injuste il n'y a plus
de présomption d'innocence pour un homme
public pour 1 personne de s'engager dans
la vie publique qui est mise en examen
alors que la loi le prévoit
lionel jospin de son côté a déjà regagné
matignon il ne fera pas d'autre
commentaire
en fin d'après midi il a reçu christian
sautter
le nouveau ministre de l'économie et des
finances